[Musique]
bon faire un petit truc je vais vous
montrer des photos de bébé vous allez
dire de quel bébé il s'agit sont autour
de la table
regardez alors par exemple ce bébé
regarder à métissage et des réponses en
plus en baisse assez évidente ce qui
nuit c'est le même maxime guény
effectivement le lapin dans les phares
la joie actuelle c'était comme ici
qu'ils essaient de dirhams où il a fait
le plus parler pour faire un deuxième
bébé temps va laisser marine a joué là
pour voir votre avis marina de qui
s'agitent en grèce à ses poursuites je
sais pas ça c'est facile alors que qui
seraient jamais gaza a dit benjamin
castaldi toujours connu à caroline
ithurbide vous êtes invités elle vient
de donner toute la crédibilité au
documentaire bon bah jean macé s'agit
non c'est pas joli à autant pas très
bien ah non et regardez il y en a t'il
ma jumelle à côté sa petite main à la
côte et une soeur jumelle depuis quand
williams safina elle était bien ben sera
lui annonça il m'a volé ma gagner comme
le football a reconnu
magali c'est magali ces nouveaux galets
oui mais ses fringues
excuse moi ma grand mère m'habillait
super bien ouais c'est le revenu
shopping après les faits rapidement
éliminé ya un autre bébé qui est on au
regard des comme ça
non pas du tout il est défaillant sur le
de vannes on regarde mon genou ces
chiffres ne savent rien
c'est jérémy non on avait là la jeune
femme qui avait une étoile ça le fait
vous avez une pomme regarder et il
savait déjà les parents qu'elle
passerait la télé qu'il fallait cacher
on a un autre ou pas benjamin si mignon
est allé ronchon reconnais mon père le
faire
[Applaudissements]
âgé mais j'avais déjà l'air heureux dans
la vie entre et surtout penser à dire à
votre peur de mettre la chemise dans
l'héritage qu'ils vont bien parce que ça
c'est bête de près c'est un coach peut
quand même les capucines mona la
voterons pas vous avez envoyé aux taux
[Applaudissements]
longs et maintenant alors peut-être que
je me dois vous savez avec le csa je
préférais très prudent les enfants
peuvent aller se coucher vous pouvez
zapper maintenant car voici la photo de
gilles verdez petit
voilà
[Applaudissements]
mais les appétits comment tu veux ma
photo
vidéo